yesterday I told you about the just
major major corruption news that Donald
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
had received $200,000 from eighty four
hundred thousand dollars from
pharmaceutical giant Novartis and
allegedly five hundred thousand dollars
from a Putin connected Russian oligarch
business owner and stormy Daniels's
attorney Michael avenatti also said that
his investigation has actually tracked
the total of more than four million
dollars to this shell company named
essential consultants owned and
previously registered by Donald Trump's
personal attorney Michael Cohen the
timing of all the payments was really
odd to say the least the AT&T payments
led up to the repeal of net neutrality
the Novartis payments seemingly led up
to a dinner between the Novartis CEO and
Donald Trump in Switzerland although
Novartis has since in coming clean about
everything said that the timing was
merely coincidental and the payments
from the Russian oligarch well the
timing of that one's sort of obvious
because there's a much broader Russia
story that we've been discussing and it
now turns out that it wasn't just four
hundred thousand dollars paid by
Novartis to Michael Cohen but rather 1.2
million dollars this story is very
quickly growing into one of the biggest
political finance scandals in a very
long time because not only did Novartis
admit that they paid 1.2 million dollars
rather than the originally reported
400,000 but they also said and this is
where it gets endlessly fascinating
Novartis also said that Michael Cohen
was quote unable to do the work for
which they hired him at the rate of a
hundred thousand dollars a month for a
year or 1.2 million dollars so the
question is what did Novartis hire
Michael Cohen to do health care policy
consulting work that's how it's being
described now this might be sort of a
stupid question but what on earth does
Michael Cohen know about health care
policy and why would he be charging
anybody to consult on health care policy
why would anyone hire Michael Cohen to
do health care policy
Consulting and 1.2 million dollars is a
lot of money for health care advice from
a guy who knows nothing about health
care so the obvious question is if it's
not really for healthcare consulting
were they looking to buy influence
rather than advice and if so where did
they get the idea that giving Michael
Cohen 1.2 million dollars might be a way
to buy influence with President Donald
Trump and that's why they say that Cohen
was unable to do the work right they say
we hired him 100k a month
1.2 million for the year we met with him
for the first time in February of 2017
and we realized he wasn't able to do
what it was that he wanted him to do
that we wanted him to do
but they kept paying him anyway and
remember this entire thing was dismissed
as fake when Michael avenatti went
public with the allegations it turns out
that not only was Michael avenatti right
about his original allegations it's even
worse he was talking about $400,000 and
we've now learned it's 1.2 million
dollars it also seems that the
originally reported $200,000 from AT&T
paid to Michael Cohen's company was
closer to $600,000 and we have also
learned since yesterday's news about
this that Robert Moeller's team has been
aware of this for a while
Robert Moeller's team contacted Novartis
about this months ago AT&T has said
Robert Muller's team contacted them
about this a while ago and what we're
slowly getting here is a picture of a
pay to play scheme right an influence
peddling scam so big that it might be
way way bigger than even the four
million dollars that Michael avenatti is
claiming and I think there's another
important thing to mention here this is
all money running through one company
that we've heard about essential
consultants the reason we know about the
existence of essential consultants is
because when stormy Daniels was paid
130,000 dollars in hush money the money
came from essential consultants so then
Michael avenatti was able to start
looking into that company there could be
entirely other shell companies through
which even more money was being funneled
to Michael Cohen or to other Trump
cronies that we just don't know about
yet the scale and scope of this Pat is
stunning given that it was all written
off his face
48 hours ago and you have to wonder
whether or not Donald Trump is more
directly involved with all of this
because Trump self describes as a greedy
guy is he only to let someone who works
for him make all of this money and not
get anything for himself I don't know
the one hand it's hard to believe that
this doesn't benefit Trump in some way
on the other hand you know Cohen is a
guy who has a long history of behavior
that is certainly not what we would call
the standard for ethical lawyering or
whatever but what's clear is Cohen's in
trouble right and and the next question
is Pat is mentioning is to what degree
does this tie to Donald Trump and we
don't know right what we do know is that
White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders has refused to say
whether Michael Cohen remains Donald
Trump's personal attorney as of today if
he is that means that the personal
lawyer of the current President of the
United States has been receiving
millions of dollars in shady consulting
money through a shell company while
being the lawyer of the sitting
president which would be absolutely and
totally stunning and the picture that's
being painted is one of Cohen as a
pass-through to Trump now it might not
be as a pass-through of money right so
Pat says that is Trump Trump's greedy
would he really allow Cohen to keep all
the money well maybe he would but maybe
it's not money that was passing through
Michael Cohen but the desires of
companies were being passed through
Michael Cohen to Donald Trump and we
just don't know yet and you know money
is everywhere in our politics so I
wouldn't be surprised if something
similar happened under bush or Obama but
maybe not to this extent but Trump was
supposed to be the person to drain the
swamp he was supposed to be the person
who couldn't be influenced by outside
interest be resonant he had so much
money that was what he ran on and what
might be true is that Cohen influenced
Trump not by giving him some of this
money but he might have influenced him
just by being his personal attorney and
being the guy who tells Donald Trump
what it is that he should do but
remember we were told Cohen has no
connection at all to policy or the Oval
Office
or the administration major story every
day gets bigger the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we our
viewers
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership